[THEME MUSIC]
So now that we've
created our achievements,
let's look at how we
can start unlocking
these things within the game.
Now, I'm going to go back into
my game, and maybe the best way
for me to do this is put all
the achievement unlocking logic
into a second class.
So I'm going to create
a new Objective C class.
We're going to call it
Achievement Manager.
This looks like a
good place to put it.
And we're all done.
Now I'm going to
start off by declaring
just one public method here,.
And it will be Unlock
Achievement with ID,
and it will take an NS string
that is our achievement ID.
And to implement
this, it's actually
pretty straightforward.
Let's jump into our
AchievementManager.m file here.
Once again, warning us that
this method is not found,
and still looking
for that hotkey
where you can create a step
method to implement this.
Someone help me out.
Someone tell me in the comments.
But in the meantime, we've got
some very easy tab completion.
And we're going to assume
that in this method
we're going to be passed in
that Achievement ID, that string
that the developer console
gave us to uniquely identify
our achievement
within the system.
So the first thing we're
going to want to do
is take this
achievement ID string
and get an actual
achievement object out of it.
And so this achievement
is represented
as a GPG achievement object,
and we'll call it unlockMe.
And we can create it by using
the GPGAchievement helper
method, AchievementWithId,
and we'll
pass in our Achievement ID.
And at that point,
this unlockMe object,
which is an achievement
object associated
with a particular ID, we
can now call its method
unlockAchievementWithCompletionHandler.
Within our completion handler,
we get back two parameters.
The first is a Boolean saying
whether this achievement has
been unlocked before, and the
second is an error object.
So we can just add in some tests
for those, If Error, NSLog.
Oh no, got an error.
And we can see the error
localized description,
something like that.
Otherwise, If Newly Unlocked.
Again, we could probably
unlock something
that says, hooray,
achievement unlocked.
And otherwise, we can just
log something that says,
"looks like you've
earned this one already."
Close brackets.
By the way, this
checking I'm doing here
for If Newly Unlocked
then do something,
otherwise don't
do anything, this
is purely for logging purposes.
It's purely informative.
There's nothing I need to
do with this information.
Both the fact that
the achievement has
been unlocked will be
recorded on the server,
and that little toast
that pops up that says,
hey congratulations,
achievement unlocked,
here's the icon and
description, that's
handled for you automatically
by the game's library.
So there's not actually
anything I need to do here.
I'm just demonstrating
that we do
get some interesting information
back to us by the system.
So now let's call this.
And so I'm going to go
into our game model.
And I guess the first thing
we need to do is let's import
this GMNAchievmentManager.
And we're going to make
a property nonatomic,
strong, Achievement Manager.
And I suppose we can link and
perform some lazy instantiation
here.
We can say if not
Achievement Manager is nil,
then Achievement Manager
equals alloc init.
And then we can return
Achievement Manager.
There you go, some nice
lazy instantiation.
And now that we have
our Achievement Manager,
what we can do is, in
our Player Guessed area,
if it turns out that the
player guessed correctly,
let's unlock the
first-timer achievement.
So Achievement Manager, or
self.achievementManager,
I guess.
Unlock achievement with ID.
And we're going to have to
go back to our developer
console here, and we're going
to have to copy and paste
this first-timer code.
Now, this is admittedly
a terrible style,
hard-coding this string right in
the middle of all of our code.
And we'll fix this
up in a little bit,
but for now I just
want to get something
working so we can
see what happens.
So there we go.
That's all we need to do
to unlock an achievement.
I suppose if I wanted I could
just embed all that code right
here in the game model.
But I kind of like having
it as a separate class,
just because I do feel like
it's its own bit of logic.
It deserves its own class.
Maybe as a further refinement
we can make a singleton
or something if at some
point in the future
we need to access it from a
bunch of different classes.
But for now, we've got this in.
Let's see it in action
and see what happens.
I'm going to run this.
I'm signed in.
Once again, let's
view our achievements.
Looks like I haven't
earned any yet.
Let's play an easy game.
Higher than 50, lower than 75.
I've gotten really
good at this game.
Lower than 56.
Let's do 53.
Lower than 53.
What do you think, 52 or 51?
Let's do 52.
Hey.
And look at that.
We got our achievement
unlocked toast
that appears right
on screen and then
fades out after a little bit.
We can go back to our main menu
here and view our achievements.
And there it is unlocked.
And it's now moved to
the top of my list,
because the unlocked
achievements generally
appear at the top.
And I've now been
informed that I
have unlocked a total of one
out of four achievements.
So there you go.
That's unlocking an achievement.
Now that we're able to do
that, maybe the next step
is to increment an achievement.
And we can look at incrementing
the Centiguesser achievement
in the next lesson.
So I'll see you shortly.
[MUSIC PLAYING]